Now you can edit out any extraneous sounds like I have to clear my throat, not kind of stuff.
We can, yes.
Okay.
Alright, so let's start if you would just introduce yourself, say your name on today's date
and our location.
Okay, my name is Kenneth Hedberg.
The date is September 9th, 2011.
Okay, Ken, where were you born and where did you grow?
I was born in Portland, Oregon in February 2nd, 1920.
And did you grow up in Portland?
Well, I actually know.
I spent my first six years of life there and then my father had a job that took him to Southern Oregon,
the Kusbe region, which is that time where we lived as called Marshfield.
And after that we moved to Hokkien, Washington, where I spent my years from age about 12 to 16.
Or upon me moved to Medford and I went to school, graduated from high school in Medford.
What were your parents' occupations?
Oh, well, my mother was a housewife.
During the war she worked at the Naval Station in that story.
My father was called a wholesale grocery salesman.
In those days, groceries were delivered by a truck from a large warehouse to the retailers.
And my father would travel to these small retail stores, some of them in outlying rural areas,
and take their orders for groceries, which he would then write up on a form in the late evening early in the morning,
take it to the warehouse and the orders would be filled.
And the trucks would then take these groceries out to the various stores that had ordered them.
That, of course, passed pretty quickly in the time of better communications.
So that business is faded now.
So that was disappeared, actually.
That was a job that would require some moving around the family?
Yeah, well, my father had actually know that he changed jobs.
He worked for a company called Mason Urban, which is now out of business,
and they had several stores, warehouses, and southern Oregon and Medford and Cuspe,
and in Astoria, and he worked in all of these places.
For that company, as they move things around.
Well, these rural stores were, of course, separated wide intervals,
and they were grouped together into what my father called a route.
And I'm given the other week, he would go on a certain route, take him all day long,
and the next day would go on a different one, and the third day, and so on,
for five, six days a week.
So it was a lot of driving, and some of it over quite significant distances.
That's about as much as I accompanied around a few of these drives,
just to keep him company, he seemed to like that.
But it was, from my point of view, pretty boring, if I'd sit in the car or go into the store,
while he took orders, and, of course, he'd have to stand around when the proprietor was waiting on customers,
because the customers were served first, so there's a lot of waiting and watching.
I'm glad I wasn't in that business.
Did you have any siblings?
Yeah, I had a sister. She died about three or four years ago.
Her child, of course, removed as a family.
I don't know, nearly as much. She moved in a different group than I did.
She was two and a half years younger.
So her high school group, her friends, were well behind mine.
So we didn't have much of a social interaction as kids.
We just said different groups we were with all the time.
She went to Oregon State for a couple of years,
and then the war came along, and she was a very good secretary.
So she dropped out of school and served as a secretary to a naval officer at the Naval Air Station in Astoria during the war.
And afterward, he set up a Ritter State business, and so she went to California,
served as the office manager for him, and she married a young man from the area.
And so she lived most of her life in San Francisco, in the San Francisco area.
She retired over the...
and the... I forgot what it was called, the tunnel from the Bay Area, across into the valley.
Pleasanton.
What were your hobbies as a boy?
Well, in those days, we didn't have anything of the sort of thing they have now.
We had quite a lot of family interaction the evening.
I remember when my father was home early enough, and on weekends, we played family cards like Rummy and Pinocchio and things like that.
The only source of entertainment apart from the movies was the radio.
And I can still remember my father and mother eagerly listening to certain programs in the radio among which were Amos and Andy.
Do you know that? Yeah. Amos and Andy. And a few of the other things.
And as for activity, I took up tennis when I was in Hokeham, and I played tennis all my life, including on the Medford High School team and on the OSU team when I came here later.
So that was a hobby. And the other one was we had a lot of group of pretty closely knit kids in the neighborhood.
And we played a lot of football, touch football on the streets.
And that's mostly, oh, I collected stamps, but that was, you know, everybody collected stamps on those days.
And that's about, I guess that kind of summarizes what it was.
No cell phones, nothing, no TV, nothing like that.
You were calling interested in science as a boy?
I was always good in school, although I never really realized that I skipped a couple of grades.
During the, my real interesting science developed, well, I was always interested in it, but it wasn't clear to me that I was going to be a scientist as a professional.
And through high school and so on, science was always easy for me, both physics and chemistry.
And when I lived in Hokeham, there were a number of people who always came to me with questions about science.
Excuse me.
I didn't, we didn't have homework in the same way then, but it seemed to come so easily to me that I didn't have much trouble answering the questions.
And then when I graduated from high school in Medford, it was in the height of the depression and my father had just lost his job.
And we were, I graduated in 1937 from Medford High School.
And there was no employment at all for young people.
There was summer employment, which I avail myself for several years.
I worked in the orchards, picking pears in Southern Oregon.
I did all this by hand, and that's about the only income that I had.
There's nothing that a young high school guy with no specific skills could earn money at.
I moved along here and there for 25 or 50 cents. That's about the going rate then.
But I made good money in the orchards when I worked there. It was very hard, back-breaking, hot, dusty work.
But when your young man doesn't matter very much.
So back to your question, after I graduated, I began to wonder what I was going to do.
And I know I wanted to go to college and my parents, neither of whom had gone to college.
In fact, my father finished the eighth grade and my mother graduated from high school. That was a limited of their education.
Always told me they wanted me to go to college and said that they would match every dollar I could earn.
Well, they pushed and put an end to that, of course.
So one day I went to the Medford Public Library. I can still remember. And I walked in and that checked out a book in physics, elementary physics, and another one in chemistry.
And I took them home to read them. And the physics that was exposed in those textbooks of the day was pretty elementary stuff, mechanics, levers, and that sort of thing.
The Manhattan Project had not a radioactivity. That sort of thing was something that didn't penetrate to the high school level or in the textbooks of the time.
So I finally decided I liked chemistry better.
And that started me on my career.
I managed to, in 1939, in the winter of 39,
as my father, as I said, lost his job. And he was important living with his brother, trying to land another job.
We had almost nothing in Medford, my mother, and my sister, and I,
and I was able occasionally to provide a little bit of money for groceries.
My father tried to send money, but at one point we were enough destitute so that the power company turned off all the electricity, and we cooked with a stove with some wood.
And we had a camping lantern, a coal and lantern that we used in the evening in the house.
We managed to avoid getting thrown out of the house, which is a rental in Medford, but just barely.
So for some reason, I'm not able to, at this state, remember how or why, enough money was gotten together to allow me to register as southern, what was then called southern Oregon Normal.
No, it's southern Oregon University. It's southern Oregon State University, I guess. I don't know.
And for ten cents a day, I had a friend with a car I could pay him, and I rode back and forth with him, stayed at home, and I registered for chemistry and a few other things, and took a number of courses in music.
And that continued. I got all A's of first term. My father told me somebody in Portland had said, you know, there was a guy, Kenneth Hedberg, I noticed that got all A's of southern Oregon College.
Is that your son? My father knew nothing about this.
And I guess my mom didn't want to tell him that we had found money to send me to college, but the tuition was a bag of tell.
You know, it was something like $20 or $25 a term at that point.
So he said, no, that can't be my son. When it turned out it was, he was not angry. He was delighted, actually.
So I stayed the second term, and I got all A's except for one, which is a B in piano. I had taken a number of courses in music and harmony and composition and things which interested me.
And at the end of that time, excuse me, this is going to show up on your, you're going to have to edit out these throat clearing.
Well, at the end of that time, in the spring of 1939, my father actually got a job in Astoria, and he and my mother decided that rather than she going to Astoria to join him, she would move to Corvallas and allow my sister and me to matriculate at Oregon State.
And she would set up a rooming house there. That rooming house would, we'd have three or four people staying with us. And she would do the cooking and so on, and the rent and things that she collected would enable us to maintain a house so my sister and I could go to school. That was done.
At the time, I didn't realize what a sacrifice that was, but as time has gone on, I can see that was a monumental contribution on their part because I wouldn't have been able to go to Oregon State at all.
Excuse me. Well, that was followed through. And I had one scholarship, tuition scholarship, dualist use. So I didn't have any tuition to pay.
And then the National Youth Administration was set up by Franklin Roosevelt, and this enabled students who qualified to earn 25 cents an hour. And I got a job in the chemistry department here at Oregon State handing out supplies to people who were in the laboratories.
And that continued for 1941, 1940. And then 1940, my mother decided that we were now able to do this on our own.
And so she moved. We closed the house and she moved to Astoria. And I had pledged a fraternity. And so I had a place to live and my sister moved into a co-op at Oregon State.
And so I lived in my fraternity house for the rest of my career at OSU. I finished in December of 1942.
Pardon?
Which fraternity were you in?
I was in the state of Kay. It's still the same house. And in fact, fraternity rode there and not changed much at all. I guess the houses have been renovated. But my social connections with the fraternity are essentially zero.
And I have a lot of professional connections that I've spent my energy with.
What was your social experience like in college?
Oh, the social experience was tremendous. My grandson is just mature, is just enrolled at...
I don't think he'll come in the minute, but anyway, he wrote back. He's a very studious guy. And it's superb, yeah, and he wrote back to my daughter that how much fun he was having.
And she was greatly concerned that he wasn't studying. He just landed on the campus. Well, I told her that was my experience at OSU.
I don't know how much is known about those days, but there was a lot of social life and the community was more strictly defined as the independence as they were called on the Greeks, which concluded all of fraternities and authorities.
And there were lots of social functions associated with the university on the students behalf that I don't see now, but that may be because I'm a retired faculty member.
But every Friday, I think it was, they had on the campus when I was a student, something called the Nickel Hops.
And this meant that all the sororities, in particular, I'm not sure about the independence, but all the sororities, cleared away the stuff in the living room, and they had music that played, and men would move from one house to another, and you paid a nickel to enter and dance with the girls that were there, and so you'd go from one place to another.
So that was one way, easy way of getting acquainted with girls.
The other important social affairs, or series of social affairs in the campus who are a bunch of formal dances, there was something called the sophomore cotidian, the junior prom, the senior ball, and then something called the military ball that was put on by the oral to secret.
And these were formal dances. The women wore long dresses, and the men wore, on some occasions, even tuxedos.
But no less than a dark suit at any rate, these ties everywhere.
And they were events planned pretty much long in advance. So you got yourself what was called a dance card, and you went around to your friends, and the fraternity, you exchanged dances.
You came with your girlfriend, of course, but you exchanged dances. You didn't dance with her the whole evening.
So you generally saved the last dance, and the first dancer yourself, and a couple in between, and then you would be trading off with friends.
I don't know what happens these days, but I look back on that with a good deal of illness. That was lots of fun.
The campus was highly regulated in the sense that, well, the putt and blunt terms, it seems to me that the university regarded itself and was looked at as a de facto parent in the absence of a family, you see.
So there were real restrictions, particularly on the women. If I remember this correctly, closing hours in all women's groups, there were very few married students, very few on the campus.
I only knew one, one couple in chemistry. So the students generally lived in living groups. A few of them had apartments, but not very many.
And so these living groups, the women's living groups, had strict closing hours. The women had to be in by 9.30 on a school night.
That meant they were going to the library. They were out of their living group at 7 o'clock in the library, and of course they could meet boyfriends and so on there.
Or you could arrange with your girlfriend to meet her at one of the Monroe Street places that served coax. You'd have a coax or something like that.
But they had to be in by 9.30. And if they weren't, if they were late, they could be penalized by having their...
Well, I'm forgotten. The penalties varied quite a lot, but they could be campused, which meant that they had to stay in their living group. They weren't allowed to do certain things that they otherwise would have been allowed to do.
The men had no restrictions at all. In my house there was a real strong million forced study hours from 7 to 9. The house was supposed to be very quiet, and it was.
So, academia flourished at those times that a study did. The other thing I didn't comment on, there was no alcohol available anywhere, not in town.
I think there was something like a two-mile rule. There would be no retail outlet for alcohol within two miles of the campus.
And that prevailed until rather late in the history of the institution.
What you see along on road street now is a lot of places where you can get beer and other things, and the students are clearly enjoying their Fridays like today at the Brew Station, for example.
But on those days you couldn't get it. In fact, Oregon... I forgot what the date of the overturn of prohibition was, but alcohol was slow to come to Oregon in the sense that, first of all, you could only buy it in the green front. You couldn't buy it in a restaurant, but you could bring your bottle in a restaurant.
And they would charge you a corkage fee and serve you. But a long time for that to be overturned.
So there's one incident that I can tell you about that I've mentioned it before, but it was really quite remarkable. I think it was in the winter of 1941.
I think it was before Pearl Harbor when we had a tremendous ice storm. I don't know whether you've heard about this ice storm, but what happened was,
we had a freezing rain, and this was on the night of one of the old school dances, which were held by the way in the Memorial Union Ballroom.
The size of the institution when I first, in the fall, maximum size was... I remember 4,200 students. So the end-of-the-year ballroom could generally contain all the people that wanted to go to a formal dance.
A lot of people couldn't afford going, so they didn't. Well, anyway, in the end view, on this particular occasion, there was an ice storm that began early in the evening, and people began to show up.
And as the evening drew on, the rain, which had continued, began to develop into a freezing rain.
And the trees began to be branches, began covered with ice. All the power lines were covered with ice.
And as the dance went on, all of a sudden, maybe 8,39 o'clock, the lights went out.
And what had happened, of course, is that the power lines were down because of the weight of the ice and so on.
Well, this is an all-school dance, and it was dark. You see, no lights in the end view ballroom.
So, somebody scrummed up the candles and put them around the edge or some other form of light.
But the end view lounge, which is very much the same as it is now, is a place where in these dances, couples would repair to rest a while and sit, smooch with each other.
And when the lights went out, you could imagine the glee that that was greeted with.
Well, then after a show, I happened to be up in the lounge at the time with my girlfriend at the time.
And the lights went out. And due course, there came one of the shaperones, usually a wife of a faculty member.
She came in with a large candle lobby, with lighted candles, and she put it on a big table in the middle of the room.
And then she turned around and she walked, and she walked back to the stairway down into the ballroom.
She got to the head of the stairs and disappeared. One of the students there got up, walked over to the candle, and all the candles out to her great chairs.
In a few minutes, the same woman came back, and she lit the candles again.
And she turned her on and walked away, but she didn't get to the head of the stairs this time before the student, maybe the same one, went up and blew them out again, again to great chairs.
This time, she never returned.
It turned out the lights were out as a consequence of that storm for the best part of a week.
And that was devastating, well, devastating. It was extremely hard for my mother because we cooked on an electric stove.
And we had all these students there, four of them, plus my sister and myself.
So she prepared the meals as best she could using pots and pans and so on in the fireplace.
We had a fireplace, fortunately, and she could build a fire and do that. So essentially we camped for a week.
We remarkable experience. Well, as far as the campus was concerned, the consequences of that ice storm were devastating.
The campus in front of the MU at the time was covered in a large number of trees, beautiful trees.
Perhaps many of them, Elm trees, I don't know.
The ice storm actually broke the branches off of these trees to the point where it looked like a tornado and hit that section of the campus.
You could walk through it in a daytime. It was still freezing. You could still see the ice.
Branches lying everywhere on their trees, effectively denuded of their branches.
Well, I led to the removal of most of the trees in front of the Memorial Union.
I suppose it was true if some other places on the campus also. I don't remember that, but I certainly remember the MU before and after.
The MU was a remarkable thing.
That's more or less the way social life was said, well, football, of course.
Oh, there were a couple of other things. Football was mostly for the students and a lot of them went.
But you weren't allowed to come with a girlfriend.
The men and women sat apart.
If you walked in with a girlfriend, there would be a raucous cheer from the men's section and they would shout the word fusser, which was a...
And that term was a sort of epithet.
There used to be a directory called the fusser's guide here.
That was for people to look up the addresses and phone numbers and other students.
And there were some of the townspeople went too, but the stadium would only hold a couple of thousand, I think.
There were only three thousand people, just one grandstand along one side.
Maybe some install bleachers. I don't remember that.
But there were also organized on the campus four times a year. It may have been six, but certainly four.
What we're called, Lysia, Lysium in the singular.
And these were events that comprised visiting artists of one kind or another, who often music.
And I have heard Hartter Rubenstein play the piano here for Oregon State at one of these.
I've heard Paul Robeson sing.
And a number of other people, like the really famous artists, would come.
And that was paid for, I don't know how, but how the university resources because your student card admitted you to these.
And they were held in the old men's gymnasium, if I remember this correctly.
And with a small student body, you always had enough space.
I was going to, I lost the throttle when I was thinking about these Lysia, but they were looked forward to.
And a lot of people in the Oregon State students who are largely rural students, agriculture was the biggest college on the campus or school it was called.
And I guess this is regarded as an opportunity to expose them at least to a kind of a cultural side of life.
They were quite remarkable events. And I was enthralled.
I didn't, there's no history of music in my family, but I thought these were marvelous events.
So that was essentially in a way the campus was set up.
The old, I was going to say the basketball games were also played in the men's gym.
And the basketball schedule was different then what it is now.
We have those called the Northern Division and the Southern Division and the Champions of these two would meet for the Champion Coast Championship.
That's the athletic side of the things there.
So what else can I tell you about the times?
Well, I'm interested also in what your academic friends was as an undergraduate.
Oh, well, after Southern Oregon Normal School, it was quite a change.
Now, the normal schools were coaches, you know, were teachers' colleges.
And so there was no major in science at all. And I just had elementary chemistry by taught by a well-meaning lady that really didn't know very much.
A couple of years later, one of my friends told me that his brother was there in the same class as I was.
This brother told my friend that I knew more of the chemistry than the teacher did.
I don't know whether that's true or not, but at any rate, that gives you kind of a level of instruction there.
Well, when I came to OSU, that was a different matter entirely.
And the first thing I took care was a course in analytical chemistry.
And I was dismayed at my first grade in an exam in that course because by my Southern Oregon Normal standards, it was a very difficult exam.
And I didn't do very well on that. I think I got a C or something like that, but I wasn't used to that.
So I learned what I had to do to work hard. And I ended up with a B in that first term for which I was very grateful.
And generally speaking, I did very well here after that initial shock.
And there was a lot of interaction between faculty and students because the classes were much smaller.
It was a good experience.
And I enjoyed it a lot. Of course, the war broke out.
So I say, I spent a year here. Since I was in science, I was deferred until I graduated.
And the campus was pervaded by a sense of what was going to be happening to almost everybody, the men on the campus.
So a lot of the students chose paths that would take them into the military, offices, training, that sort of thing.
ROTC was required at that point.
I'm sorry, I have to cough. I have this just allergy that comes this time of the year.
That just about finishes my recollection of my undergraduate days here. Well, as I say, I played tennis.
And we played Oregon, Washington State, Washington, Idaho. And to get to these places, we traveled by car.
And usually that was the car of our tennis coach. It was a guy named Bill McCallop, who also played football here.
And what's on the faculty is a football coach of some category or another.
So we drove. Yet the Idaho, we drive a car, you see. And then of course, we'd arranged to play Washington State at the same time.
So that was a long trip in and by present standards, a kind of uncomfortable car. But we were young and it was lots of fun.
Were all of your chemistry classes in Gilbert Hall or did you ever have classes in the Kimsack?
All the chemistry classes at that time were in Gilbert Hall. There was a building down on Jefferson.
And then what was now 15th Street? That used to be called the Kimsack.
Lennon's Pauling, of course, met his wife in the Kimsack. And I've often walked him around the campus.
And one time when we were walking down there, he wanted to go into the building and we went up. And we went onto the floor and he went into one of the rooms there.
And I can't remember whether the configuration was different from what he remembered, of course.
But he was able with reasonable certainty to identify the room in which he was teaching when he met Eva Helen.
And he gave me a couple of amusing incidents about the Kimsack in those days.
What did he say?
Pardon?
What did he say about the Kimsack?
Well, there was one famous incident. And you see, we didn't, I guess he didn't have natural gas as we did later on as when I was there.
And so when you had a burner in the laboratory, this was generally burning gas, perhaps so subtly.
And I think it was in a steel tank. And that was mixed with oxygen and other Jason's tank.
And these were admitted into the laboratory by Hoses.
And there was a guy there, an assistant of some kind, and Pauling told me his name, but it was a foreign name, an Indian name, or something like that.
A student who was working there and being paid to do certain things. And he managed to get these lines connected up in the wrong order.
In such a way that when he turned on the tap, the higher pressure in the oxygen tank forced its way through the tube into the acetylene tank outside.
Well, the consequence of this ultimately, for reasons that I run explain, was an enormous explosion and fire that destroyed the stock room in much of the section of what was called the Kimsack.
And Pauling said he never knew what happened to this student he wasn't hurt. Nobody was hurt, it turns out.
But Pauling didn't know whether he had managed to get his degree or not. That much he was able to tell me about.
When I read the Kimsack, I had a reputation for catching on fire.
Did what? I had a reputation for catching on fire.
Did it? I don't know. Well, this was certainly one.
And you can see why. I thought it was the method of firing up burners.
The chemistry nowadays is done in much more batches usually in the undergraduate lab than it was then.
I mean, if you made a preparation then, you made a pound of it, I'm exaggerating, but I mean, you had a lot of stuff there.
Nowadays, it's all green chemistry, very small amounts of things.
And the summertime, I worked once on the... I don't remember whether I worked two summers or just one summer in another vacation period.
On the campus is a part of the surveying crew.
And one of the guys who stayed with us and my mother's uprooted rooming house was a guy who was a civil engineer and had a standing summer job.
And he ran this line of levels. And so he taught me how to hold across things and so on.
He taught me what the signals were and so on.
And that was better than working in the hot orchards in Southern Oregon, but I didn't earn a lot more money out of it. I can say that.
That was your stock room, dumb.
Oh, this is a stock room job. You signed up. There were a number that was all student-operated.
Well, there was a head of the stock room. A man named Stoney Wells. I remember that still.
One of the reasons I remember it because I mentioned that name to my father. And he said, Stoney Wells, I know him.
So I brought him around one time and they shook hands and reminisced for a while. I don't remember what the connection was.
But the students were the ones that actually did the legwork and taking in glassware, handing it out.
And those days you checked it out. You had a pad and you filled out what it was you wanted.
And handed that to a guy behind a window just like at a shouts someplace.
And he would go get the items and give them to you. And then there was a return sheet.
And when he returned it, the items had to be clean and dry. You put them back, looked at the sheet, made sure everything was there.
Put them back and then matched it up with the checkout sheet and threw the tool away.
So things were borrowed and returned from the stock room. And we who did this work behind the window were what we were being paid for by NRA, NYA.
National Youth Administration.
The first year I got 25 cents an hour and the second year I got a raise to 30 cents an hour.
But that was big money in those days.
You could buy a Coca-Cola for a nickel.
And you could go to a movie or something like 25 cents.
And a full plate lunch would cost you 35 or 40 cents. Something like that.
I remember my childhood in Hokeyam. My father and my mother was away.
And my father and I went out to a local rooming house called the Finnish boarding house in Hokeyam.
And they would serve meals to people who came in. It was family style, a big long table.
A bunch of silent guys sitting there and spooning it in.
And the cost of that for the two of us was something, for each of us something like 20 cents a piece.
It's just a bag of tell by today's standards.
Unbelievable.
Were there any classes or teachers that made a big impact on you in the undergrad?
Oh yes, there were.
JP Meilig was a very long-term faculty member here.
He was an analytical chemist.
The first man that I really met on the faculty because that's the first course I had to enroll in here.
He lived to be over 100 years old.
And he was a man of incredible precision in everything he did.
His analytical chemist seems to fit his personality because he did everything by the clock and by rules.
People used to say, JP Meilig always walked to work and he lived down on eight streets or something like that.
And he would walk up Jefferson to the chem shack.
And I was told, I don't think the story is apocryphal, but maybe the...
I mean, people used to stand and wait for Meilig to walk through the gates.
And they said, you could almost literally such a watch by his coming in.
Well, I had a little...
He got his degree at Purdue.
And he never ceased to be very interested in what Purdue was doing.
And he subscribed all his life to the student daily newspaper of Purdue.
He used to go back there for the summers to do research.
And he drove his car.
And every year he changed. He bought two new tires, either for the front or the back and older than at the years.
And those days, tires didn't land nearly as long.
And then the war came along. He couldn't get tires. And he was terribly upset.
It turned his life around in an uncomfortable way because he was so used to buying these tires.
There was another man later made a great impression on me.
And that was a man named James W. Ferguson. He was an organic chemist.
And as a war broke out, of course, he left and he went back and worked for the Midwest for Eli Lilly Company.
But anyway, I learned an enormous amount of organic chemistry from him. He didn't do a lot of research.
But he was certainly a superb teacher from my point of view.
Another person, of course, was Bert Christensen, who became department chairman after I returned to the faculty.
He was remarkable in a way because as a faculty member, because it was very hard to do research here at the time.
Federal grants didn't exist then. The kind of structure we have now, like National Sun's Foundation, didn't exist.
So you had to do everything more or less on your own and you got very little contribution if any from the state.
But he managed to involve himself in research, both with graduate students and undergraduates.
And I worked for him for a year or so.
And a very interesting project that we finally published.
And that was my first publication with Bert Christensen.
There was another guy named Bill Caldwell. I never had as a teacher.
But he was a very popular instructor of freshman chemistry.
He had very fancy demonstrations that the kids liked a lot.
And then of course, there was EC Gilbert, who was a physical chemist.
But I grew to know all these people as a student.
Of course, when I came back in the faculty, all the ones I mentioned except Ferguson were still here.
Ferguson, after he went back to Eli Lilly, he returned to Oregon and he went to Portland State where he finished his career there.
And after I came back on the faculty here, I saw him a few times in Portland.
He looked just the same.
So those, of course, I knew other faculty members too, but I didn't have them in any of the coursework that I took.
So that's a project that you did with Bert Christensen, that was your first experience of science in the research?
Well, it was called, are you asking what kind of work it was?
Yes, and that was your first research project.
Well, it was called a micro-determination of hydroxyl group.
And it was an analytical technique where you work with very small amounts of sample using microbalances, seal them up, and then a reaction took place.
And then we could analyze the mixture and we could determine one aspect of the composition of the molecule.
Later on, when I worked at Shell Development Company, I learned that our analytical method was being used in that commercial analytical lab.
So that was really pleasing to me. They were big time down there.
So by the time you were done with it, at OSU, did you decide that you wanted to be an academic?
No. The war was on then.
And I was faced with a decision about what I was going to do.
And I had two opportunities.
The war work was going on in the chemical industry.
And in particular, there were people from Shell Development Company who came around and they were looking for people recommended by the faculty to do war work on some of their projects.
The other opportunity, and I was interviewed by them on offer to the job.
The other opportunity was to go into the air force in a program that would have been, for me, in meteorology or on armaments, not in flying because at the time my visual acuity wasn't very good.
So I had been registered with a draft board.
And I went to see Gilbert. He was a nice guy. I liked him a lot.
But he kind of grumbled. He would talk in a little voice. He said, I think it's ridiculous for you to go into the air force and not use your chemical training when you could do that in war work where they need skilled people.
So then I went down to my draft board and I talked to the chairman of a draft board.
And I think his name was Cindy McCollum or something like that. And at that he was clearly a scot. And he ran a gas station downtown.
And I explained the situation to him.
He said, young man, you better go in the air force or we're going to draft you.
Well, this caused me to think a little bit about this.
And at that point I knew I wanted to go to graduate school, you see.
To make a long story short, I finally decided that I would take the job at Shell Development Company, which was professionally extraordinarily valuable experience.
But in terms of emotional contentment, it certainly wasn't very relaxing.
Most of all I spent most of the war on 1A, which is the draft status, eligible for the draft.
And you never know whether you're going to be drafted.
And well, I guess I shouldn't have said it that way. When you're in 1A you're eligible to be drafted and will be drafted.
So I was always classified 1A by the draft board.
The company appealed to the appeal board in Oregon on grounds that I was doing war work and supplied the paper verification of this.
And because of the secretive and important nature of this war work, I was always reclassified in the deferred status of 2B.
Now, this deferred status lasted for only 6 months, dated from the time that you were first classified 1A.
Well, it took about 3 months for this process to go on and for you to be reclassified 2B. But by that time you only had 3 months left.
So I spent literally half of the entire war years in 1A while the process of keeping me deferred to do this war work went on.
And it's more than just paperwork because before you're classified 1A, you get a notice on the draft board that says greetings.
And then you have to appear for a physical. So they would tell you, first of all, I had to appear at 5th of Monroe for a physical.
I said, I can't do that. I'm in war, gauging war work down here.
Real transfer your physical down there. All this took time, you see.
So then I would take the physical or I would go down. I'd be transported to San Francisco up to the procedure.
And there are a whole bunch of potential draftees were lined up and we went through a physical that took at least, well it took all morning and the most of the afternoon.
At which time?
You either classified as physically capable or classified for aft which means incapable of military service.
So at the end of this I was classified 1A. My draft board was notified and they told me I was 1A. Then the company would get the papers and they would appeal this and we would go through the whole thing again.
I did that about five times I think during the war. And on one occasion just before the war was ending both in the Pacific, both in the Europe theater, was in 1945 and I had an emergency up in Dectomy.
I was in the hospital in Oakland for over a week, bed ridden. They didn't allow you to get up or anything. I had a huge scar like this.
So anyway in the middle of all this my nose to appear for a physical. But I knew that if you had a recent serious operation and that was serious in those days, you're automatically deferred for six months.
So I tried to tell them that I had a recent epidemic that says take your physical. So I lined up down in Oakland and we knew of course we were transported across the bay with a hundred other guys you see.
I told a strip there and I said to the corpsman and the first corpsman I said I've had a recent epidemic in Dectomy and I said I'm supposed to be deferred for six years as getting mine.
I got in line. I came to the next corpsman I said the same thing to him. He said getting mine. I went through all the tests and saw them pass them all and came to the last guy who was in office there and there's a guy who's supposed to test with your men.
He said he was supposed to test with your mentally fit. He says likeologist and he'd look me up and down and said you had a recent epidemic in Dectomy and I said yes I've been trying to tell him that all day long. He grabs my papers and he writes deferred.
Lastly the war ended. There was still going to be occupation forces and the war ended of course in the Pacific in August of 1945.
A lot of the military were being decommissioned and sent home and so on. Then the year were rolled around and the question was who are they going to have in the occupation forces.
At this point of course there was no further need of my services in this war work and so I was eligible for this.
But on the 2nd of February in 1946 I turned 26 and they didn't take anybody over 25.
So then I was automatically out of the occupation draft group and then I entered Keltek in the spring of that year left Schilddevelopment company.
What was the right to do with yourself?
Oh well there were several things. The Japanese of course had succeeded in overrunning all of the plantations that provided latex for natural rubber which was of course really needed during the war.
So synthetic rubber had been discovered and there were all sorts of ways of making synthetic rubber. So I worked a lot on the problem of synthetic rubber.
Another thing that developed about this time during the war was the discovery of the efficacy of penicillin which is being produced in a traditional way.
In our area by cutter laboratories it existed in either in Emoryville or in Berkeley or Oakland right down there close to the bay.
They had huge vats and they cultivated this and separated the penicillin which was distributed the arm forces was not available to civilians at all at this time.
And I worked on the extraction the methods for extracting penicillin from this.
The third thing that I did was and that was probably the most interesting in many ways was a aviation gasoline inhibitor.
No aviation gasoline at that time was 100 octane fuel because all the aircraft were propeller driven and there was a high performance engines that were required that level of anna quality.
This was particularly during the North African campaign and these tanks of 100 octane fuel were shipped across and then they had to stand on the desert.
Now one thing that happens to gasoline is that over time they tend to form some gum which settles out to the bottom.
Now that gum if it gets into the engines of course can be a very serious matter.
So they apply what are called inhibitors to delay or greatly slow down the formation of this gum.
And the stockpiles of fuel there in North Africa had in them a dye, a red dye.
It turned out that when the gum was formed this red dye would be occluded and take down the fuel would change color.
So the sergeants running the dump would realize what was going on and they would then use this deteriorated fuel and jeeps and in motor vehicles of various kinds.
Well of course it's obvious that what you want to do is to prevent this from happening as long as possible because that's expensive fuel to be using in jeeps.
Then it turns out that a lot of the time that the stuff was gone the dye was disappearing the fuel was still good.
Well we had a special inhibitor that was better than anything in use that we were developing and testing in the desert with a drum that we had mounted on the Mojave Desert at an army base with a bunch of thermocouples all through it
because we needed to figure out how quickly the gum formed in accordance with weather conditions.
I mean if you store these drums I mentioned in North Africa in the winter there's no problem it's cold and in the summer it goes to pot very quickly.
Well how do you know that because you don't know what the temperature inside the fuel is because in the summer a barrel at the bottom might be relatively cool and one at the top would be totally gone.
Well we had a way we put these thermocouples all through this test drum and then we could measure the rate of formation of gum as a function of well we took these temperature data from the thermocouples all through the drum
and worked that up into something that we could call an effective temperature for the whole drum and we could predict from a thermocouple in any place what the effective temperature was in the whole drum.
And that would tell us how long that fuel could be expected to last and so we did that in addition to developing and testing our inhibitor which turned out to be very good.
Well the war ended before the inhibitor could actually be used and then of course the fuel now is not under octane anymore so that never got into production but if the war had gone on much longer it would have been.
So that's the kind of thing that I did and all of this laboratory work was a tremendous aid to me when I entered graduate school because I know how to use my hands.
I've been doing it for three years in the laboratory.
This job was in Southern California.
Yeah it's a Keltaq.
Oh was that Keltaq?
I went to Keltaq.
But the shell job?
Oh the shell was it was an emery bill.
It was called shell development and emery bill was a small enclave between Berkeley and Oakland on the bay.
So were it about an hour and ten minutes do you want to keep going or do you want?
I can go longer I probably should leave here about quarter to twelve if you want.
We can do whatever you like.
If you're if you're feeling empty but definitely like to keep going.
So you finished up at shell and then you went to Keltaq.
What was the process by which that happened? How did you mind if you'd come back?
Well the laboratory I worked in at shell.
I should say just a little bit more about that.
It was a small laboratory.
A shell development there were all sorts of projects distributed all over.
There was a motor lab out and back in which gasoline were tested.
I was in the research end and there were the head of my small laboratory and another guy who had been working there for a long time.
And I was brought in as a third guy to help these people.
We became all three of us very close friends in a social as well as in a professional sense.
The man who headed is named Daniel B. Luton Jr.
He was a remarkable person.
He was a very good scientist.
And at the same time when the war was over, during the war he got very interested partly because of this North African stuff in climate.
And thereby associated himself with geography.
So he knew a great deal about geography all over the world and especially about climate changes and temperature and so on.
And he used to amuse us by coming up with some facts that you didn't know.
He said, where do you think the rainiest July in the world is?
Where is the place where the rainiest July takes place?
Well right away you think monsoon or something.
It turns out there is some village called Chara Pungi India in India.
And he said in the monsoon season he announced to us that it had something like 240 inches of rain in the month of July.
These are the kind of facts that he would come up with.
Well the reason I mention all this is that after the war was over he retired from Shell as a chemist but became so knowledgeable in this other area that he was appointed an adjunct professor of geography.
And as time went on he built quite a reputation in that field.
He came to Oregon State, gave lectures here, was invited up on the geography department.
He was a very very interesting guy.
The other fellow was just as interesting.
His name was Aldo de Benedictus and he was an Italian obviously.
He came from an Italian family who was engaged.
They had a business in making pasta.
And one time he told me he says, don't let him kid you.
He says the dough is all the same.
It's just the die that makes the difference between pasta.
So the texture is different depending on the die but not the dough.
Well many graduated from Cal.
He was an excellent student but he had a family of several children and he had to go to work.
But not having a doctor's degree he was not running the lab you see but Dan Luton treated him in every way as an equal.
He had his own projects and everything.
Well he spoke Italian fluently and Shell had occasion to
want somebody that knew Italian very well to serve as a translator and so on.
And after the war he moved out of chemistry into marketing for Shell where his language skills could be useful and he moved to New York.
Well he did very well in the company. He moved up the ranks.
Finally when he retired officially from that aspect of Shell they moved back to Berkeley, he and his wife and family.
I guess his kids were grown and they lived there at the time.
And then he told me he became very wealthy after he retired.
And he told me how this happened.
There is a company knowing as...
I'm thinking advanced micro devices. It's not that one. It's another one that makes chips.
It's the biggest chip maker in the world now. Chips for computers and so on.
No, no. No they make...well I'm sorry I'm a spoke.
I think they make the devices for making chips.
But he told me, Benny told me, we called him Benny, that he was approached by some people about this project.
And he said about five or six of them sat down around the kitchen table in his house in Berkeley.
And he decided he would...they all put up $10,000.
And that company just grew like wildfire and he ended a multi-millionaire just by investing that money.
And so he endowed a chair at Berkeley in chemistry called the Aldo de Benedictus Chair of Chemistry.
His wife went to UCLA and was a nutritionist.
And he set up a similar thing in her name at UCLA with another million dollars.
This was done years ago. It must be worth a lot more than that now.
So I thought that was quite a remarkable story for a guy who spent his youth making pasta and working in a chemistry laboratory to end up like that.
Okay, so Caltech, what decided me to go there?
Well I was thinking about going there and I wrote the EC Gilbert and he said, well you asked, you know there's a very good university right there where you're working.
That's University of California. For some reason I wasn't interested in going to Cal. I don't know why.
But it's a tremendous institution of course and great people there.
But maybe I had enough of that area for the while.
And so I applied to Harvard and to Caltech.
And in due course I was admitted to both of these as a student and then I had to make a decision.
And so I talked to Dan Luton about all of this and he said, well I said,
Caltech has got Linus Pauling. Who else do they have on the staff?
And I knew a lot of people at Harvard, you know, very famous people. But the only one I knew at Caltech was Linus Pauling.
And Luton with his customary brusquen sense of humor manner, he says, look, he says with Linus Pauling they don't need anybody else.
That was his famous line to me and I've never forgotten that well. That wasn't enough to decide me.
But what did decide me was that it was only a short distance away.
It was on the west coast in a place which at that time was reputed to be beautiful as indeed it was all right.
And I had a small beat up car that I knew wouldn't make it across the United States.
And so I packed this thing up with my duds, my wife and myself and we started out for Caltech.
And I'll tell you this too, this is more a personal history than it is a professional history. I guess maybe that's all right.
Well, this was a 1933 Chevrolet Coupe.
And it had been repaired once and I started out. We hadn't loaded my wife and myself. And we started up a steep hill out in the valley just before you get into Southern California.
And the car began to falter and it wouldn't go anymore.
But then if I stopped it, fired up the engine, it would catch and I could go a short distance and go, it would stop.
Just as if it were tired, you see.
So then I turned the thing around and managed to get over in the other lane. It wasn't a freeway on those days.
And I went down at the bottom of the hill. The car ran just fine.
Pulled it up into a gas station which was closed for the evening.
And it had a mechanic associated with it.
And so I pulled into this gas station. There was a light on in the house and back and I asked about mechanic. I came to the door and said, well, I'm a mechanic.
I said, well, I hate to bother you. I guess you're closed. This is, yeah.
This is what's your problem. I explained this to him.
And he put down his knife and fork. You're literally having dinner and he went out and he listened to this and looked.
He says, you need to know a few of them.
He says, I don't have one here, but I think I know where I can get one.
And so I said, gee, that's very kind of you. And he said, no, no, that's okay. And he gets in his car and he goes away in 10 or 15 minutes.
He appears and he's got the fuel pump.
And then he gets to work on my car. It puts a new fuel pump in on those days. It was a fairly simple job.
He said, I've got to give you a new fuel pump in. We fired it up and he says, there, that ought to do it.
And I said, how much do I owe you? He says, well, he says, you pay me for the fuel pump.
And I said, I got to give you more than that. He says, nah, nah. He says, sometimes you just have to help a guy out.
That is a lesson. You know, that happened when I was 26 years old. I had never forgotten that.
And to my last angry grad, I never learned the guy's name or the location of this, but I had never forgotten that.
Absolutely remarkable. You know, he spent a lot of time and he wanted nothing for his time.
So I didn't know that you were married at this point.
Yeah. But that was my first wife. We divorced some years later.
My second wife was, I met a Norway and we've been married for 55, 56 years or something.
Anyway, they get back to Caltech. So, I know where the hill got down, found a place by then wife at a relative there who offered to put us up for the night to not her husband was a postman in Pasadena.
And he on his rounds happened, knew quite a bit about vacancies and so on, which were very, very few.
And in that time, in that area, there were a lot of houses that had garden colleges and back of them. And he knew about one of these.
And I went up to my wife and I went up, interview these people.
There were old people, 80 years older so nobody was in the house and they had fixed it all up.
They were very particular about their tenants. And after I guess we turned on the charm, but they agreed finally to rent it to us.
We were then able to wheel up our fuel longings and put them in the house, which was furnished.
And we lived there for quite a long time.
When I went to Caltech, I presented myself at the main office and I said, I'm on appointment Mrs. Wolf, Beatrice Wolf, who's his secretary.
She said, well, Dr. Pauling likes to talk to all the new graduate students, I'll set up an appointment for you. And she did.
I can't remember whether I got an office right away or not. But at any rate, I do remember the interview with Pauling.
He knew that I was from Oregon and from Oregon State. And of course, there was a kind of a bomb there because he had gone to them.
Not a bomb, but at least there was something in common. And so he asked me when I was interested in it. And I told him I was interested in chemical kinetics and mechanisms and so on.
And he said, well, he said, it's too bad because the right person for you to work with would have been Roscoe Dickinson.
And he died last year of cancer and we haven't anyone to take his place yet.
But he said, we do have a young postdoctoral fellow here from Mac East.
And he's interested in this kind of work and doing a project. And it would be fine for you to work with him if you would like to. And he would like to have you.
And this day, my mind is boggled at that because you can't imagine our department chairman here suggesting that any of the incoming graduates students work with a postdoc and not with a faculty member.
His hands are very hard to come by and your research program.
So I went to see this man, his name was C. Gardner Swain, who later went on to a distinguished career at MIT as an organic chemist.
And I worked a full year for him until his period was over. And we did a project, a project of his that turned out just fine.
And we published a paper on it together.
What was the drug?
It was a oxidation of a local malachite green to malachite green carbonyl, was an organic compound, which then decomposed or, yes, to form a dye called malachite green.
We could study the reaction by watching the color formation of this stuff.
So it was a fine project. And it was good for me because I was good for Gardner because I had had all this laboratory experience during the war.
Probably had more than he had at that time in the actual laboratory work.
But he was a very clever guy. And if we wanted to do a reaction at Shell Development Company, we had all the equipment on the shelf there.
I could bring down what was called a thermostat, a constant temperature bath.
I could put up the control mechanism and put in the controlling thermometer and the heaters and so on.
I had to have it all set up in 15 or 20 minutes.
At Caltech, they didn't have any such thing.
So Gardner sat down. He was good at electronics and he drew out some components that we would need.
And I went up to the avenue to an electronic store and bought these things.
Came back and spent, you know, how long?
A couple of weeks or three, maybe even more than that, taking courses. Building is relay that would work.
Building and putting it together, soldering wires and so on.
And then I spent another week locating and getting transported a big tank, which I could fill with water that would hold our samples.
I set up the heater and put everything in it and got it going. It took me the best part of six months versus that 20 minutes I mentioned to you.
Once it was set up, reactions, experiments went rather nicely and conveniently fast.
That got done in Gardner's year there.
That was a good experience. So at the end of that time, I had to decide I was looking ahead.
What else I was going to do?
And there was a young guy there. He was only about six years older than I was that had a very, very good scientist.
He'd done his work with Pauling and the Nannah to the faculty.
And he had a group of young people that were kind of eager and I went to talk to him.
And the upside of that conversation, so I decided to work with him and we had a project that we settled on right there.
So Gardner left. I began to work with this man whose name was Werner Schumacher.
So maybe we should talk about some of this at a later time.
So I can do that.
What I can do is send you an email.
Why don't you send me an email and suggest some times because I think I can fit more easily than you.
Now next week I'm going to be in Ashland going Tuesday and won't be back to the weekend.
Is that okay? The week following that we can do.
Let's see.
We're looking into October now, Chris.
No, we're not.
After the Ashland week I'm free every day except Thursday when the president is hosting the Emeritus faculty at a luncheon.
So Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday and Friday are all available.
Okay. And the next week is entirely free.
That's the week beginning the 26th.
Okay.